all right guys I'm so excited about this
video I just got done packing to go to
Aruba which is an island I've never been
to before but my girlfriend and her
family go every single year she's been
going since she was 2 years old and I've
been dating her for three years I've
cancelled every single year because I
had to film or travel this year had to
cancel because I was getting surgery on
my ankle but the surgery just got moved
to a later date so I literally just
bought a ticket I'm gonna be surprising
my girlfriend in Aruba I have no plan I
don't know what's gonna happen you guys
are just gonna come along on the journey
I literally just bought tickets all I
know is that I need to go to bed because
I'm waking up at 2:00 a.m. to go to the
airport let's do it
[Music]
it is two o'clock in the morning let's
go
[Music]
Oh airport's empty everything's going
super smoothly my girlfriend's not
enticed to me she's asleep in Aruba so
surprises uh going as planned
[Music]
so I guess right now would be a good
time for me to tell you how my
girlfriend night met basically my friend
in my doing to this post-prom party I
knew nobody there I didn't want to go
and I just randomly I don't know why I
decided to go and I went there and I
noticed her right away and I was like so
flustered and overwhelmed I didn't know
what to say to her and my phone was
dying and all I said was hey do you have
an iPhone charger and she was like yeah
and then she left and I was like great
well that was a dumb pick-up line
because I just used her and have nothing
to talk to her about because she's gone
now but she ended up coming back and she
strike the conversation and we ended up
talking until 8 a.m. we spent the whole
night just talking it was incredible was
the first time I felt a connection to
somebody like that the only way I could
tell her that I liked her for some
reason was by giving her my phone and
saying you can delete my tinder which is
a terrible line if you like somebody
don't say that ever but I guess she
liked me so she kept talking to me 3
years later we're still dating and it's
been it's been awesome
[Music]
so I just landed and I got a voicemail
from Sabrina in the middle of the night
she does that sometimes when she can't
sleep I'd be just wanted to
I just can't wait to see you after the
new year I love you so much
all right so I just got to the hotel I
have like 30 minutes before Sabrina
wakes up plan is I want to write
something like massive in the sand have
her seat from the window and then pop up
behind her in the hotel room one minor
problem Sabrina's sister just texted me
and the only thing they can see from
their window is this little section of
rock so I need a new plan I got an idea
Sabrina's sister texted me that Sabrina
woke up so while she was getting ready
in the bathroom I snuck into the room
quietly took out my sticky notes and I
started to write Sabrina and I used to
always text each other 50 things we love
about the other person so I thought why
not post 50 things I loved about Sabrina
around the hotel which would lead her to
me on the beach however really bad
feeling about these sticky notes I feel
like someone there was all the cleaning
crew was just like looking at me as I
put on this I should have told him not
to do anything with this you know I'm
gonna go check I'm gonna go check on the
fake you know super quick lipstick
somebody removed the sticky notes
somebody clean them up oh my god I knew
that was gonna happen I'm so dumb all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna text Gabby
right now I'm gonna tell her to get rid
of the sticky notes in the in the house
and
just bring to the beach to take a
picture I'll surprise her there all
right that's the plan
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]